&gt;&gt; Well this equation certainly makes things a little bit easier. Because we did
the same thing to both sides, I mean, didn't do anything crazy, like try to
divide by 0, whatever answers we come up with from here on out will still work
for our original equation, either of these two right here. The difference is
that now when we solve, we only have to deal with two factors that are
multiplied together instead of three, like we had when we had that constant term
out here as well. Let's think about what we can deduce at this point. We have
two factors that when multiplied together give us 0. Let's call one of them a
and the other one b. Then we can write this equation as ab equals 0. Thinking
about this equation, can we conclude anything about what either a or b should
equal? Please answer yes or no.